[Music]
welcome back we're going to do a little
quick interview with rob o'neil and talk
about the stuff that's been going on i
have a question for you when isis when
we decided to take out isis and i say we
as in me in america
uh
we annihilated them and that was a
roughly what is it i don't know how many
was it 70 100 000 fighters we yeah we
annihilated them at first but then when
we decided to leave a war zone and leave
it into a vacuum as opposed to just
bombing a convoy we just didn't do it
and and again i i don't want to blame
any one person bad decisions are made
all the time in in combat but right now
keep the base bomb the bad guys yeah you
have there's there's a picture of them
in the presidential palace right by the
way the president ghani left and he had
so much money in his helicopter he
couldn't close the door but they're
really yes but they're taking pictures
in his um weight room it's like yeah
here's a crazy idea drop a j damn on
that place yes if you know where he is
if you know where they are
that's all you have to do his name how
ironic his name is ghani
never even put that together i'm going
to steal that joke please do you surely
need them
no offense in case you were wondering
well
[Laughter]
thank you you're welcome um your show
um should i be skeptical about the new
improved taliban
you know you know what you never talk to
them you talk to the telephone i
actually have i asked are we are we like
exaggerating no no no they're brutal
they're really really brutal but i did
have taliban guys tell me over over um
we're eating rice out of the same bowl
but for some reason we have cold
coca-cola with no ice i don't know how
they do it wow but
what they have told me is if they knew
that we were as serious as we were at
the beginning with the bombing and the
fighting they would have given us al
qaeda um
maybe not because they're two different
people al qaeda's foreign fighters in
afghanistan anyway and i don't think the
taliban has interest in attacking us
here they want their valleys they want
their mountains i want to be optimistic
because i think hopefully no and i could
be i'm probably wrong but uh hopefully
they just want to keep their country and
you know not let the press and then just
murder people how can china i mean
because china because china will crush
you yeah china's moving in right now
they're making get all the minerals for
the e-bikes of course they're gonna do
it uh batteries for my e-bike but see
they have to go back rob well see the
the taliban understands you mess with
china they will kill you yeah look at
the uyghurs yeah seriously they're
horrible they're they're both horrible
china's tougher so you know notice the
russian embassy didn't close russia will
kill you yeah we decide um boy i hope i
don't use harsh language yeah exactly
but by the way we're too busy reading
anti-racism books to our church oh yeah
we're we're doing that yeah i mean we're
putting building new bathrooms we've
been putting our own
troops in prison for for murder in a war
zone yeah which again i feel like i'm
taking crazy pills um it's it's
frustrating to see and you know i've
talked to so many friends today that are
just what do we go for yeah it's it's
very frustrating yeah did you get
anything from cat because those were
crazy pills
yeah she said it was a it was i was
taking a vaccine
do you um
i i've been reluctant to bring up heroin
but it fuels the taliban financially and
i was just wondering if that was their
vodka or that was their pot why didn't
we go into business with them i don't
know that's why no no their vodka is
still vodka their pot is still pot it's
all there it's just that china doesn't
care how the money comes in neither does
russia we're just we're so woke and so
politically correct that we can we can
screw anything up with wokeness wait and
see all right um also
what did this uh this botched
exit was without question one of the
worst except that we don't have any
comparison
to it is it possible that it would have
been bad no matter what you know what
there is a comparison and i don't want
to screw this up but john f kennedy when
his first in office and the bay of pigs
he said that victory has a hundred
fathers
um defeat has zero yeah and as an orphan
and i take responsibility
and joe biden president joe biden came
up and said i accept all response
does the buck stop here yeah i'm not
seeing you or the chairman joint chiefs
resigning anytime soon yeah there you go
all right rob
that was interesting
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else